wenn wir zu schnell öffnen dann steigen
die fallzahlen wieder und es gibt dann
nicht nur eine verlängerung der welle 2
mann starke welle wieder an wir sind in
einer wohl marable phase dass ein
wiederanstieg der fallzahlen zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht sicher
ausgeschlossen werden kann was bedeutet
das das bedeutet dass ich hier noch mal
bei dieser gelegenheit auch appelliere
an alle teilnehmer der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und
insbesondere an den
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten selbst nicht über
die beschlossenen lockerungen hinaus zu
gehen das ist mein appell wirklich wir
müssen das umsetzen wie ein uhrwerk wie
ein uhrwerk aber wenn wir jetzt
zusätzliche lockerungen einführen wenn
wir versuchen uns zu profilieren als
jemand der besonders schnellen locker
jemand der
versucht mit lockerungsmaßnahmen auch
politische geländegewinne zu machen das
wäre falsch